when I was in my teens my uncle Amy
bought himself a house for ten thousand
dollars which was very cheap even back
then it'd be incredibly cheap now and it
was in the middle of North Central
Illinois near a town called Tonica and
it was on a street that terminated in
this state park that had some canyons
and there was an old abandoned brick
factory nearby and basically he just
lived in one of these houses along this
street and it was you know basically a
County Road he had a Tonica post office
box so he'd have to go in every once in
a while I don't think there was actually
mail service to a lot of these houses
along the street and the first time that
I came to visit him it was in February I
I was 18 years old I was getting ready
to go into the army so this would have
been you know 1989 or so and then I
visited him again in uh it would have
been
1994 after I finished college and it was
me and and my girlfriend at the time
dropping in to stay for a little while
and then the other time that I stayed to
visit was after my first year of
graduate school so we would be talking
about the summer of
1996 and I stayed for about a week or so
and the first time that I came to visit
I'm not exactly sure how the logistics
worked out but he must have been up uh
near us in Wisconsin and invited me to
come down and stay for a while and I
think I stayed for maybe five or six
days and it was incredibly cold you know
the winds blow out of you know Canada
across the Great Plains and into uh
Illinois which is largely at that that
point pretty you know flat in in many
respects so there's not an awful lot of
forest so it can get pretty rough in the
winter there was snow everywhere it was
colder down there than it was up by us
in Wisconsin you know several hours
Drive North and so we'd stay in his
house you know and he had heat we stayed
it out of the screened-in porch because
it was super super cold there he didn't
heat that part of it it was a small
house he had lots of books and not a
hell of a lot else other than his you
know carving tools and stuff like that
but aim was a social guy and so you know
the day after we got down there and I
remember him giving me what we call a
pile cap it's one of those those caps it
was actually his from the air force that
has like ear flaps that you can you can
button up and um
you know we uh in the morning got up and
we walked down the road and we went to a
place that was called the store right
and it was a general store and it just
so happened that my cousin Ben Ames
first cousin my second cousin had
purchased this a while back and was
making a go of it and he uh the store
was not just a general store where you
could buy groceries and stuff like that
it was also a restaurant and it was kind
of like the you know the the place that
everybody went to not just in the
morning but through the rest of the day
to meet everybody else and talk about
stuff and have some coffee and warm up
it was heated by a iron uh you know pot
belly stove that you'd feed wood into a
lot of wood burning stoves down there
and it was so so cold right we'd come in
Amy actually had a full beard and
there'd be like icicles in his beard
from condensation right and so we go in
and we're you know having breakfast in
the morning some coffee and eggs and
stuff like that and you know catching up
with my cousin Ben and some of the kids
going in and out and chit chatting and
stuff like that and then there were the
the locals right
and we would we would talk with them and
some of them would tell Tall Tales like
one of them was an older guy who told
this clearly false story about you know
growing up on the Mississippi River and
some kid getting dragged down by an
alligator gar that was 18 feet long and
they you know set off depth charges in
the river and up came you know an
alligator gar that had bits of this kid
inside probably not any any truth to
that story but a lot of people would sit
around and tell stories or they would
play cards and you know have some more
coffee and stuff like that and then you
know we'd go back to the place and he
introduced me to some of his other
neighbors everyone was very friendly out
there one of the neighbors I remember
not on that trip but on a later trip
kept raccoons kind of a dangerous thing
to do kept essentially feral raccoons
cooped up in a giant cage and they were
trying to domesticate them and and that
never really worked all that well and
one of the girls actually got got
scratched by one of them and then they
got rid of those but some of the other
things that were really cool about being
out there was you know as I mentioned
there were these Canyons there was this
state park I think it was either a state
park or County Park and and it you know
you'd walk down the street all the way
to the end and then there was some
stairs that you could go down and then
you were in this massive cool area there
was like a creek flowing through it
that's how the Canyons had been eroded
over time and so we would you know take
hikes through those areas and you know
we'd walk around other places as well
and one of the things I remember about
that time was just you know always being
cold in one way or another you you might
be like close to frostbite or you know
you might be warming up by this stove
but your back was getting cold or you'd
be snuggled under a bunch of blankets
and you could see the you know your air
coming out of your mouth your breath you
know condensing and looking almost like
smoke and of course both everyone was
smoking back then as well smoking
cigarettes and
um
we had a good time you know there were
some parties during that time as well
and Ben had a party room at the time
that we all gathered in and shot pool
and drank beers and smoked cigarettes
and listened to music and told stories
and all of that sort of stuff as well
and I had a good time for those you know
four or five maybe six days before I was
supposed to go back up to Milwaukee and
report for induction in the the U.S army
and it was it was a nice time I'd quit
my job I was no longer going to the the
dojo to practice I had a lot of time on
my hands and one of the cool things
about like hanging out with aim and
living out there on the you know the
plains in Illinois with him for a while
was you could constantly hear the wind
and there was plenty of silence as well
nobody felt like they had to chat better
and talk all the time and you know you
could read a book if you wanted to you
could Whittle you could do other things
as well and so that was that was you
know quite refreshing I mean it was
really Spartan circumstances but I was
already kind of used to that anyway I've
you know at that time in my life I'd
lived you know fairly uh let's say
frugally not necessarily poor but I
didn't have an awful lot of stuff and so
it didn't bother me at all and it was
nice just to like hang out and enjoy the
uh the cold and the dark and the you
know the quiet of snow and the constant
you know of wind as well
so that was that was one time there and
then you know the second time that I
stayed as I mentioned I had a girlfriend
of sorts I should say she was actually a
German exchange student who I kind of
treated as a girlfriend but she was
actually cheating on her fiance with me
so you know it wasn't all that
surprising when later on she she cheated
on me with with some other people but um
after school ended after college ended
we took my car and we drove around to
different places and you know I thought
well we'll make a cheap trip out of this
we'll stay with some of my family
members my relatives so we drove down to
you know stay with Uncle aim and we that
time we actually did stay out on the the
porch because it was you know pretty
warm and it was quite nice you know when
the breeze was flowing and we only
stayed a couple days we explored the
Canyons again did some hiking which you
know I love to do aim love to do this
this girl Andrea like to do as well and
uh we explored the Old Brick Factory
which was quite extensive you know uh
there were these gigantic Kilns where
they had them the massive piles of
bricks some of them stacked up neatly
some of them just like all over the
place and it was uh pretty cool to check
out you know so that you know that
didn't last all that long we did some
more partying of course I mean I was at
that time 24 Andrea was about 28 and so
you know back to Ben's party room and
actually by that time they had
um one of Ben's kids was living in a
trailer and we hung out there and you
know partied as well got real drunk and
uh
had had a good time shooting you know we
also shot pool and they they had an
actual pool that we could swim in so
that was you know kind of a a fun time
and then the last time uh aim you know
he knew that I was in the dorms
at Southern Illinois University in
Carbondale and he'd been down to
Carbondale a couple times because I had
a few of my cousins living down there
Pat and Mish there was another cousin
those were in his generation they had
two daughters and then there was another
cousin
um I want to say may who was uh studying
like
you know uh something mechanical down
there as well so he knew the area he'd
been down in that region and so he knew
that I had to get out of the dorm and I
had some stuff and then I was going to
be moving into this trailer park so he
was like well you know why don't I come
down and I'll bring my truck and we'll
just grab all your stuff throw it in the
back of the truck and you can come out
and hang with me and then when you can
move back into the trailer I'll drive
you back down there and we'll move you
in and that that's in fact what we did
so I stayed there about a week by that
time one of my cousins was working as a
cook in in one of the nearby restaurants
so we we spent a lot of time getting
food from that restaurant and of course
there was more partying and more hiking
and more traveling around and enjoying
ourselves it was kind of funny that that
aim was not a big cook himself he
preferred to get lunch meets and make
sandwiches for himself and you know he
could boil water for coffee but that
that was basically about it you know as
far as his cooking went as a matter of
fact I found when that time I came in
his stove wasn't hooked up somebody had
unhooked it at some time and he just
never bothered to hook it back up so I I
hooked it back up and we got some
groceries and I made some meals and that
was that was kind of nice and I would
you know read through the books that aim
had if I hadn't read them already so he
was into a Stephen King phase at the
time and I remember reading the Tommy
knockers and a few other books as well
uh and just you know hanging out and
again uh enjoying time with my my family
my mom's side of the family the lemrezas
and enjoying that uh wonderful natural
environment
that you know it's not completely
natural there's Road roads there's
houses obviously but there's an awful
lot of nature big Skies lots of
interesting weather and creatures all
over the place Birds animals of
different sorts bugs sometimes would be
a problem but not too big of an issue
and so I have some really fond memories
of these times that I spent hanging out
essentially at my Uncle a maze place and
you know aside from the one time that
Andrea and I drove down it was always
aim coming to pick me up and drop me off
he was a very generous guy
he worked at you know at a
engine shop you know basically cleaning
up he took me there to see the engine
shop as well and meet the guys that he
worked with and
um you know he would do odd jobs here
and there for other things because he
was pretty handy and there's a vast
network of family members living out
there as well mostly coming from one
other branch of our big lemerys family
so you know for me this is something
that I've been thinking about lately
it's been a while since he died about
two years and I miss him a lot you know
I didn't get to see him as much as I
would have liked to the last you know
eight nine maybe ten years of his life
um but he he was somebody who made a big
impact on me in my childhood and my
teens and my 20s and part of it was by
by opening up his little home to to me
to you know kind of goofy crazy teenage
and 20-something Metal Head Greg who
loved to party and smoked like a chimney
and read a lot of books and you know had
a lot of opinions on on things and aim
was was cool with that he was the the
fun uncle and that's probably where I'll
end this story I didn't really have a
vast you know point to this but I
thought I would share that with you
um this guy my great my uncle Amy and
the times that I stayed with him down
there in Illinois